let's talk about making America great
again when you hear that term make
America great again
what do you think of my question when I
hear it is make it great again like when
and a Donald Trump supporter named
Barbara you're gonna like Barbara told
CBS news this week that she hopes Donald
Trump the Republican candidate will take
America back to a time when I guess
according to Barbara it was really great
why was it great before legal abortion
and before quote the homosexuals what
the hell is Barbara talking about I
don't know let's see if you can figure
it out here's Barbara explaining it to
us on bastok statement so great and
wonderful gonna get tired of winning
when to win so much which is gonna be
unbelievable and that says nothing they
just tells you one thing Barbara what
about you what's your what's a big issue
for you
morality and values based on what the
country was based on I think that the
laws that Obama has passed saying the
cotton way in the country has I call it
down turning some of the other people
are out of it and happy for it
I personally am against it the
homosexuals the abortions all the stuff
I am against when Donald Trump says make
America great again is that what you
hear that it's gonna go back to the
before the time that you're now
describing that's part of it first of
all there is no before homosexuals
there's before gay rights but there's no
real going back to before homosexuals
it's sort of funny but really I know
that it's actually disturbing and sad
when individuals like Barbara here
seemed to think that before there were
gay rights there were no gays which is
absolutely ridiculous
yeah that's pretty ridiculous also does
she realize who passes laws no she
doesn't and neither is Trump because it
seems like both Barbara and Trump Pat
seemed to think that President Trump can
just unilaterally change whatever he
wants Barbara thinks that he can just
outlaw abortion and outlaw gay marriage
a pair
we've heard Trump think that say that he
thinks if he appoints conservative
justices to the Supreme Court
automatically roe v-- wade is overturned
what I like is that at least there's
some consistency Barbara seems as
clueless about how this country's laws
work as Trump does and you have to
wonder how and why these issues are so
important to her it seems like if your
job is sound and you have health care
coverage and everything else then you
start going after the moral fabric of
America she seems to think that gay
people arrived in a boat some day or
something like that the day apparently I
don't know what day it was I don't know
if it was more than ten years ago in
Massachusetts legalized gay marriage and
of course everything was fine or if it
was a couple of June's ago when the
Supreme Court said no more bans on
same-sex marriage I don't know exactly
when but she's acting like gay people
arrived on a boat and I know Rosie
O'Donnell does these comedy shows on gay
cruises but it's not like gay people
showed up on a particular day and now
America has gays yeah yeah and where in
the Constitution does it say that women
don't have a right to choose
no we're yeah I know so I'm just a
little yeah this entire make America
great again thing is as depraved as
we've suspected for a very long time
what makes America great I would argue
in part the concept of how America was
created freedom to practice whichever
religion you want or none at all with no
negative consequences the Constitution
is a big part of the creation of the
United States the pursuit of happiness
is a big part of that and to me that
includes being openly gay without
negative consequences in our society and
the third thing the third area that I
believe is part of the foundation of
America is equality we don't have an
aristocracy here we don't have a king no
one has the right to power or riches
ideally unless their hard work earns it
for them or if your dad is rich and
manages to change the estate tax laws so
he can pass all of that money on to you
so the Republican Party in general and
Trump supporters who were advocating
making America great again
way that is completely counter to what
the founders of this country want this
is why it's so concerning and I know Pat
we get a lot of emails from people
saying David stop shilling for Hilary
she's the exact same as Donald Trump
that is absolutely not true and
supporters like Barbara make that clear
I love how she says there's that we used
to not have a homosexual homosexuality
as a problem at all yeah I mean it
sounds like President Ahmadinejad when
he was speaking to Columbia University
yeah when he was asked about gay rights
in Iran he said well we don't have gay
people here we just don't have gays I
still haven't figured out if that was a
joke or whether the guy actually
believes that it's either a really bad
joke or the guy's delusional I got one
email from someone who saw this Rachel
sorry I stepped on either saying David
what's scarier that this woman is
allowed to vote or that this woman is
allowed to breed and I responded that's
America and you know hopefully her
candidate loses but yes she is allowed
to vote and everybody should be allowed
to vote
yeah and it's less about about Barbara
herself it's more what she represents
about the Trump followers on the whole
and kind of just trying to go back to
this Pat Buchanan type of America and
it's quite frightening let's go back to
the Great America of a hundred years ago
when we had child labor
we had sweatshops we had Jim Crow laws
we had raw unregulated sewage we had
quack drugs with no regulation
homophobia and much more than homophobia
as just no big deal in society and of
course discrimination against women
those are the good old days that are
referred to by a lot of the let's make
America great again people I want no
part in it and for all of my criticisms
about Hillary Clinton and it's a long
list you know if you've been watching
this show for long enough then just to
email in and say I'm shilling for
Hillary Clinton you know I've got a long
list of critiques of Hillary Clinton but
that is not the make America great again
that I want what Barbara is talking
about and what clearly many Trump
supporters want Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s